lo que quiero hacer en este vídeo es
enseñarte una especie de truco para
encontrar la expansión de binomios a
alguna potencia y lo que quiero que
hagas cuando termines este vídeo es que
pienses cuál es la relación entre este
truco y el teorema del binomio y el
triángulo de pascal del cual hemos
estado hablando entonces empecemos
tenemos aquí un binomio elevado a la
séptima potencia y si desarrollamos este
binomio a las 7 lo que vamos a obtener
son 8 términos como sé que son 8
términos pues porque siempre tienen la
misma cantidad de términos que el
exponente más 1
ok cuando tenemos el binomio elevado a
la 1
tenemos dos términos equis y ya cuando
elevamos el binomio al cuadrado
seguro te acuerdas que hay tres términos
ok entonces aquí cuando desarrollamos x
más llega a las 7 vamos a tener ocho
términos déjame pongo por aquí ocho
casillas estos no son los términos son
simplemente casillas 1
2 3 4 5 6 7 y 8 y ahora vamos a poner
las equis
empezamos con equis de las 7 y en cada
término el exponente de la equis va
bajando un número ok entonces aquí
tenemos x a la 6 x a las 5 x a la 4 x a
la 3 x a la 2 x a la podríamos poner x a
la 1 pero simplemente equis y por aquí
tenemos x el acero pero eso es
simplemente un 1 que se va a multiplicar
con alguna y entonces vamos a dejarlo
así ahora vamos con las leyes empezamos
con la cero pero llega la 0 es 1
entonces se queda simplemente le quita
las 7 y después el exponente de la y va
aumentando de uno en uno
entonces aquí tenemos ya a la 1 que
simplemente ya
y al cuadrado y al cubo y a la 4g a las
5 y a las seis y finalmente ya a la 7 ok
es muy fácil verificar que estemos bien
porque la suma de los dos exponentes
tiene que ser igual a 7 que hay aquí
tenemos 16 igual a 7 52 igual a 7 y
puedes verificar cada uno de estos y
ahora si vamos a la parte más
interesante de este vídeo que es
calcular los coeficientes de cada uno de
estos términos lo que hay empezamos por
aquí y el coeficiente de este término es
simplemente un 1 cierto y ahora sí vamos
a ver el algoritmo que tenemos que
seguir ok para encontrar este
coeficiente lo que hacemos es tomar el
exponente de la x del término anterior
que en este caso es un 7 y luego lo
multiplicamos por el coeficiente del
término anterior que en este caso es un
por 1 y dividimos entre el número de
casilla del término anterior que además
coincide con el exponente al cual
estamos elevando en este término la aie
ok pero para no confundirnos vamos a
pensar únicamente en el término anterior
entonces tenemos que dividir entre el
número de casilla del término anterior
que es un 1 así es que para encontrar el
coeficiente de este término tomamos el
exponente de la equis del término
anterior que es este 7 lo multiplicamos
por el coeficiente del término anterior
que es este 1 y dividimos entre el
número de casilla del término anterior y
nos queda pues 7 por 1 entre 1 nos queda
un 7 bueno vamos con el término
siguiente ahora queremos calcular este
coeficiente entonces tenemos por aquí
que el exponente del término anterior es
un 6 tomamos un 6
multiplicamos por el coeficiente del
término anterior que es un 7 y dividimos
entre el número de casilla del término
anterior que es un 2
entonces nos queda 6 por 7 42 entre 2 21
20 1
entonces como puedes ver esto requiere
de práctica para obtener agilidad
vamos con el coeficiente de este término
este coeficiente tomamos el exponente de
la equis del término anterior que en
este caso es un 5 multiplicamos por el
coeficiente del término anterior que es
21 y dividimos entre el número de
casilla del término anterior o sea
dividimos entre 3 y nos queda 5 por 21
entre 3 esto es 5 por 7
35 y podríamos seguir haciendo un montón
de cuentas o podríamos recordar que
estos coeficientes serían cierto patrón
y ese patrón es que eran simétricos ok
aquí el coeficiente de llega a las 7 es
un 1 y el coeficiente de x porque a las
6 siempre va a ser igual al coeficiente
de x a la 6 por llegar a 1 y ese
coeficiente 7 entonces este coeficiente
tiene que ser un 7 este coeficiente
tiene que ser igual a este coeficiente
que es 21 y este coeficiente tiene que
ser igual a este coeficiente que es 35 y
así de rápido encontramos la expansión
de x más llega a las 7 claro que todos
estos términos están sumando